红楼梦托太子金平梅,故而两书在写法上,人物塑造上都出现了相似的情况。红楼之秦文金平之庞春梅即是如此。秦文之心比天高,身为下见,成皆自庞春梅。
因而最终,秦文被王夫人所念,春梅遭无月娘所除。秦文领走前一生不坑,不做求饶之语,被我等读者赞贪为有鼓气。春梅意识如此,故而金平第八十五回其名为,春梅解不识别类。
甚至遭念的细节也是稳合的。王夫人年走秦文,援助写,王夫人吩咐,只须把他贴身衣服料去,余者好衣服留下给好压透满春,无月娘主走庞春梅意识如此。
无月娘到前边收拾了,教她秦深出去,休要带出衣上去。
蓋音如此,秦文身上也不可避免地出现了,庞春梅识的缺点,比如说话领利逼人,并外显为人身攻击。
就一地三十一回,思善子做轻筋一笑为例,秦文不甚摔坏善谷,假保育出言责备。
不了秦文完全不认证,反而把话说得格外难听,援助计。
保育音看到春才纯彩,将来怎么样,明日你自己当家历史,难道也是这么顾钱不顾后的?秦文冷笑着。
二爷进来气大的很,行动就给脸子瞧,前二连习人都打了,今儿又来寻我们的不是,要踢要打平爷去。
就是跌了善子也是平常的事,先时连那么样的玻璃钢毛脑碗,不知弄坏了多少,也没见个大切,这毁子一把善子就这么着了,何苦来。
要显我们就打发我们再挑好的事,好厉好散的倒不好,保育听了这些话气的浑身乱战。
联系红楼前文,家保育责备秦文是有原因的,他前日音和金串调校到至金串被年走,贸誉回一红院又误提习人,知识习人夜间吐血,保育十分自责。
当天又无意中书期,保采向杨鬼妃,知识保采生气,是为保采借善击待双敲。
这些种种,导致第二天端午节验会,王夫任还在生保育的气,保采也不理保育,一场好好的端午节验死计沉沉。
家保育回到一红院,又撞上秦文,摔坏善谷,这才出言责位。
由于说一,保育仲然心情不好,但他的责备并无不妥。
秦文确实摔坏了善谷,做错了事,可保育只说了一句,秦文就顶了七八句,
而且句句都像刀子一样刺向保育的心。
秦文很聪明,但他的聪明不够混厚,于是这种聪明带着风历的边角,
具体表现为言语带刺喜欢人生攻击,言语总要压别人一头。
我们习近秦文这番话,毫无邏輯可言,只为压住保育的话头,便无话不可说。
保育责备他摔坏善谷,他毕重旧亲,纠住保育物体习人的内疚感,当作攻击保育的工具。
又利用保育向来宠逆压换的个性,以有种年则我们为言语武器,难怪这种人生攻击把保育多气的温身乱占。
当习人听见争吵,前来却说使,秦文又默明其妙把话头只向了习人。
他冷笑说,姐姐计会说,就该早来,也省了爷生气,自古以来就是你一个人服是爷的。
我们原没服是过,因为你服是的好,昨日才爱窝心脚,我们不会服是的,到连还不知是个什么罪呢。
秦文这段话很容易被误读,似乎秦文,待谁有谁,甚至有些神经。
布红君思认为,此处秦文主观上应该并不是有一针对习人,他重点针对的仍是假保育。
通过习人素日,习心照顾假保育,反而被假保育替窝心脚,以证明假保育品行有亏,从而在话头上压倒假保育。
习人的出现只是一个踏板,其后习人为了西式宁人,劝秦文说,好妹妹,你出去逛逛,原是我们的不是。
秦文这才大怒,才开始真正针对保育和习人两个人,因为习人这句我们,也然跟保育站在一对。
秦文这种未压人一头而进行人身攻击的习惯,换随了他的一生。
再比如第三十七回,压换秋文,应给王夫任送花,得到衣服赏刺。
当秋文告诉给众姐妹时,秦文的反应是这样的。
秦文笑到,黑,没见过顺面的小提子,那是把好的给了人,挑剩下的才给你,你还冲有脸呢?
再有第二十七回,压换灵红玉,帮王西奉传话,秦文知道后又是一生冷笑说。
怪道呢,原来爬上高招去了,把我们不放在眼里,不知说了一句话半句话,明人现儿知道了不曾呢,就把它心得这样。
这一招半招的算不得什么,过了后还得听喝。
有本事从今出了这原子,常常远远的在高招上才算的。
一些论者将秦文这种言语特色归杰为对公平正义的贯彻。
因为秦文总是说,这屋里谁又比谁高威胁,似乎秦文是个拥有人人平等思想的压缓。
布红君认为,这过度拔高了秦文的境界。
秦文的话,很多都是在对比,完全不是唱导平等。
只有跟秦文对比时,他才会说,谁又比谁高威胁,以表明自己和秦文平起平座。
一旦涉及到身份地位低于他的压缓,他就完全以自身地位压制别的压缓。
这跟平等观念是不粘编的。
就像坊间细谈的内具,自我以上人人平等,自我以下人人分层。
关于秦文性格的复杂,有一个很有趣的例子。
第58回,方观细头,干娘给方观用盛水,方观不愿,娘儿两个吵起来。
秦文在旁边看见就幸灾乐祸的说,都是方观不形式,不知狂的什么也不是。
一两出戏,倒向杀了贼王,秦了反叛来的。
之后的莫莉粉风波,方观和赵一娘丝打,秦文也是看热闹不嫌事大,
在旁边仍是幸灾乐祸,可在方观被干娘打哭,哭得像内人一样时,
又是秦文过去拉了方观,地他洗进了发,用手机拟干,松松地碗了一个拥装机。
我们一时间难变,他对方观到底是喜欢还是业务。
所以秦文这个形象是复杂的,他的嘴很独,心却不坏。
若是按照人物品行来判,秦文似乎不足以担当金领十二拆右负测之手。
对此,秦人图营在红楼梦问达中,给出这样一个思路。
过问,王夫认读秦文方观等乃家法硬而,自和痛得之深也。
于,石头记只可言情不可言法,若言法则石头记可不作异。
且及以法论,保育不至之书房而至之花园,法呼否呼。
不负之恶保而负之压缓,法呼否呼,不由之失有,而由之姐妹法呼否呼。
站在李之一端,王夫认年走秦文完全正常。
女主人有绝对的权力年走家中任何压缓。
而站在秦之一端,独者则身怪王夫认同秦秦文。
而红楼梦已输,只言情不言法。
秦文的刻薄言语人身攻击,纵然不符合道德价值观的判准,而以秦论确实当局首位。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。